modding dark souls is about to enter a
whole new level
i'm just going to let this clip speak
for itself
so you saw that right another character
just killed gwyn
and immediately chose the dark lord
ending leaving us
a spectator alone with gwyn's pendant
and
his cinders this is how dark souls
nightfall
begins and it seems like nightfall is
set just as the dark age of man begins
since we just witnessed the chosen
undead's abandonment of duty
this room is where most of our dark
souls journeys ended so it's kind of
genius to design a mod that actually
starts from this point
and it's not only the story that's
changed the gameplay has two
now this looks overpowered but later on
it becomes clear that if you want to
heal
you have to temporarily abandon this
overpowered state and you heal with
these umbras effigies
which seem to basically be an estus
flask equivalent that you find
by the lord vessel and there it is
12 cinders remain you should go and
watch the preview after this
it reveals new enemies new bosses a
health regeneration system similar to
bloodborne
there's a time travel mechanic and last
but not least
there's totally unique voice acting and
characters
gods look at you hollow as they come huh
but i suppose we can't choose our
company this far from home
dark souls nightfall featuring the
creator of
dark souls daughters of ash is shaping
up to be
the best dark souls mod we've ever seen
check the links in the description and
go and follow the mod team on twitter
because i don't think you want to miss
this when you see a bonfire
you think good the french word for good
is bon
actually and according to the 1755
dictionary of the english language
that's where the word bonfire comes from
but the 1755 dictionary of the english
language
is wrong in the 1890s webster's
international dictionary the etymology
was corrected
turns out in heathen times there was a
practice of burning bones in the open
air
something backed up by a series of
citations from the time
these were bone fires as opposed to a
wood fire
though all types were eventually
assimilated into the word bonfire as the
years passed and
burning heretics and bones became a
little bit less common
of course in dark souls undead are
constantly sacrificed to fuel
the first flame and just so bonfires are
literally made up of the bones of the
undead
so this is something that you can see in
game and it's described by a couple of
items as well
so in the end the bonfires of dark souls
exemplify the long history of the word
bonfire
they are good fires a cause for
celebration when you finally find one
and they are bone fires with a dark
history
burning deep within the history of words
is beautiful
sometimes and i love that dark souls
brings that to light
a ton of places in dark souls take after
real-life locations
something often admitted to in the dark
souls design works
and something that's often discovered by
players when they're exploring famous
landmarks around the world
imagine taking a tour of this random
castle and coming across
this staircase i feel like i would get
ptsd
like i'm about to get shot with a giant
arrow or something
this is a part of chateau de chambo in
france
and while the insides look borderline
identical to the inside of anor londo
the outside of the castle definitely
doesn't that's because from software
tend to blend architectural styles
in their castles the outside of anor
londo was actually largely inspired by
the milan cathedral
instead with its diagonal buttresses
that support
these tall striking spires when from
software art director masanori waragai
was touring this cathedral
he walked beneath these buttresses and
he thought
how fun it would be to walk on them and
sure enough
this thought became a reality years
later
this is lamont st michel a township in
normandy france
planted on top of an island specifically
it's a tidal island
located a few hundred meters from land
which makes it accessible at low tides
but makes it incredibly defensible
because of the high tides that
would come in and disrupt and sweep away
an attacking force
so this place inspired the sunken city
of new londo
which is also far more accessible when
the player
drains the water and lowers the tide of
course a lot of people will see
some similarities in the architecture as
well there are posts all over the
internet
from tourists noticing similarities in
dark souls over the years
i even noticed something when i visited
london years ago
the famous church westminster abbey
clearly inspired the cathedral entrances
in lower lothric
and irithyll as well the high vaulted
ceilings of saint peter's basilica
in italy looks a lot like the cathedral
of the deep
and archdragon peak is absolutely
inspired by the hagia sophia church of
constantinople
you can see it in the byzantine
architecture and you can even see it in
the
mosaic design of the ancient dragon
great shield
but of course not everything in dark
souls is a castle
and for truly ancient places from
software pulled from truly ancient
architecture
so these are the rock-cut caves in
maharashtra
india buddhist temples that bear this
striking resemblance to the caves
seen in upper izalith most of the
architecture in
lower izalith itself however is largely
inspired by angkor wat
a temple complex in cambodia the
architecture of which miyazaki said
possesses a kind of chaos or to put it
differently
they lack a kind of peace and order and
that's what i wanted to capture
and lastly there's the crystal caves
which are so similar to the cave of
crystals
near nike in mexico where there are
photos and
footage you can find of explorers
walking through the cave but also along
the crystals
so similar to what we do in game finally
while many have noted similarities
between the duke's archives and
the royal portuguese reading room in rio
de janeiro
miyazaki seems to admit in the design
works that the revolving staircases
at least are inspired by harry potter i
was thinking
when covert is over someone needs to go
and record
a world tour of dark souls inspired
locations
now that is a video i would watch if you
enjoyed this section of the video
please go and support from software and
grab a copy of the
official design works the interviews in
there at least
are a fascinating insight into the
development process
speaking of insight one part of the
development process
has recently been elucidated by another
content creator
lance mcdonald who unearthed dialogue
from bloodborne's doll
back when she was voiced by another
actress
hello ailing one this is a nightmare
a dream of the sick of those on death's
doorstep
minds ravaged by disease but still
clinging to life this is where they come
does that not describe yourself dead but
with renewed life
in this nightmare or perhaps your life
before was the bad dream who can recall
madness is after all
a fog so that dialogue would have played
when you first met her
and it's interesting that she talks
about the dream as if it's more of a
nightmare
casting doubt right off the bat on
whether any of this is real
in fact it seems like the concept of
madness was once planned to be
the source of your strength rather than
blood echoes
ailing one pursue a deeper madness
and i will make it your medicine i am
here for you
to embolden your sickly spirit
i guess using madness as a currency
might have turned into acquiring insight
designed to be replaced as deeper
concepts of the game were fleshed out
nevertheless
it's interesting to think about and
while there's something to be said
for the off-putting almost stilted
cadence
of the placeholder dialogue with this
actress the final voice actress of the
doll
delivers her lines in a way that makes
the hunter's dream
a much more welcoming place over the
past few years
the hacking of bloodborne has become far
more developed even leading to the rise
of so-called
false depth chalice dungeons which are
created
and save edited by the hackers but are
accessible by regular players who just
enter the glyph some of these codes have
led to
dungeons containing high-end weapons and
some have even been edited to
include cut content so that anyone can
experience it
and now there's a new incredible dungeon
a yeah it's not what it sounds like
after you kill the blood starved beast
take its chalice to the hunter's dream
and
enter the glyph kempke step forward but
don't progress past the statue to your
left
and 83 000 souls are yours
this process is over in 20 seconds and
it can be repeated instantly with a bold
hunter's mark so
if you're keen to get back into
bloodborne whether it's to quickly build
out some characters or
finally beat the game this is an amazing
tool
special thanks to the tomb prospectors
subreddit for popularizing this dungeon
i don't even want to imagine what's
happening off-screen in that far away
room
but speaking of unsettling things in
unseen rooms
in the third level of boletaria castle
in the demon souls remake
up these stairs past a fat official is
this small dead end
stand here for a couple of seconds and
you can hear a baby crying
now what this is most similar to is some
gates in the tutorial where
you can hear the demon vanguard going on
a rampage somewhere inside
they're a one-off effect and they're
also special because they seem to
trigger based on your proximity
as opposed to just atmospheric
background tracks for an entire area
some folks have also said that this is a
blood-borne reference
and yeah that could be true but i think
it's just more likely that it's a very
difficult to discover effect
meant to convey the hopeless atmosphere
of boletaria castle
where the remaining townsfolk are either
dead or dying and
this child has been abandoned and did
you know there's a part of demon souls
where it's impossible to die discovered
by illusory wall
your health cannot be reduced below 1 in
the first
section of the tutorial and it's
probably a good idea
because let's be honest if you're dying
here then you really are in desperate
need of the tips that the tutorial will
offer
but the real reason they don't let you
die here is because unlike in other
souls games
when you leave this tutorial you're
never able to go back
your first real death in demon souls
also matters a lot from a story point of
view because
it's what leads to you losing your human
form
and having your soul bound to the nexus
by the monumental
dark souls is a lonely game the ruined
world is on its way out
and is largely empty of life furthermore
communication between
players is limited on purpose except for
emotes
which is what makes praise the sun so
amazing
it captures the spirit of jolly
cooperation and
also the overwhelmingly positive spirit
of solaire
who just contrasts so wonderfully with
this dark world
but this emote actually existed long
before solaire
it first appeared in demon souls and the
reason so few people know about this is
because
miyazaki was actually hiding it from the
higher ups at from software
at the time as well who wanted it
removed
according to the dark souls design works
that pose
actually carries some significance for
me during demon souls
that was a holy sign when i presented
the game to the rest of the company
i showed them that pose and one of the
higher-ups told me it just wasn't cool
enough
of course i told him i'd get rid of it
but i secretly kept it
in the game so naturally with dark souls
i was determined to use it so this is
what it looks like when you normally
cast a miracle
in demon souls but this is what it looks
like when you cast a miracle in demon
souls
while you have the ring of sincere
prayer equipped
the time it takes to perform this
animation actually increases your spell
casting time
making you more vulnerable to attack but
it increases your miracle power by
almost 50 percent
your character isn't rushing this
miracle it is more
sincere after all so praise the sun is a
representation of
sincere prayer and sincere faith and
it's no coincidence that this is perfect
for the character
of solaire who sincerely believes that
he will one day
find his own son so we've talked about
developer names for enemies
hidden in the load list code of souls
before but
i've never mentioned the name for the
giant depraved one one of
the worst enemies that you can aggro in
the valley of defilement
as discovered by a luxury wall its name
is just
two giant eyes drawn in ascii art and
staring right back at you yeah no that
describes it perfectly
actually speaking of eyes sakura has an
ability
called night eye as described by one of
the loading screens
it's what allows fay's keen sight in the
dark and for all of his regular skins
his eyes turn yellow but on the sureskin
they turn red
you know interestingly ishin the
sculptor and even emma
they all have lines about the shadow of
shura in your eyes
and it's just one of those from software
attention to detail things where
yeah you can see shura in someone's eyes
before i go i'd like to let you all know
that all existing posters
including the painted world which i know
a lot of you loved
they're all now available on print for
the first time and they're viable
with the link below so this week only
i'm offering 10 off so
check them out if there's any you like
if you want to get them framed this is
the time
some of them look great framed and you
can get the dimensions for the prints on
screen
and you can just take these to any
framing shop or there are a lot of
places online that will just do custom
frames for your prints
as well and yeah that'll look really
great
i'm excited to finally bring it to print
and teespring do good posters at
a budget price as well so check that out
alternatively of course you can buy
these on display
if you're looking for something more
premium but
anyway thank you as always for watching
and i'll see you next time
you